protectyourbubble.com
proud sponsors of swipe on sky news
you're watching swipe coming up on the
show this week
living with disability the high tech
solutions helping make life easier
leading ladies we meet two of the uk's
best-known paralympic champions
and boxing clever making the most of
what you are in our games review
and welcome to swipe this week we're in
birmingham at the nadex exhibition it's
the uk's largest disability home care
and rehabilitation event and our sky
news colleague max preston who has
cerebral palsy has been taking a look at
some of the latest high-tech innovations
this is how i see the world but with
constant advances in technology i can't
help but ask whether it always has to be
this way so i've come here to nadex to
find out
now this wheelchair from boulder is a
very snazzy bit of kit allowing its
users to more directly engage in social
situations by getting up to eye level
with others as well of course as
stretching their legs and as an everyday
wheelchair user i have to say it feels
relatively normal
but what if you couldn't even use it
without being helped out of bed every
morning
well it turns out that like much else
there's an app for that
it's called care pair it's a bit like
the uber app but for the recruitment of
personal caregivers
the website part of it you sign up
either as a carer or as a user of care
and you say what you can provide or what
you need help with and the system
matches people together based on those
criteria that have been put in
the safety issue is down to the employer
that's employing the carer it is their
responsibility with their funding to
make sure the relevant checks are
carried out there aren't many
regulations on it when you're employing
carers directly so actually it's up to
you to choose what you want however
useful and safe its customers may deem
it many disabled people simply can't use
their hands well enough to enjoy
conventional smartphone technology i'm
one of them but that may be about to
change as the team at doro say they've
come up with an answer but overcoming
communication challenges is just one
facet of being disabled
what if like me you're keen to get more
exercise well happily shukri from
medical tech was on hand to help
a few years ago during an extended stay
in hospital i got a lot out of using an
accessible gym bike like this one but
when i asked my local health authority
how much it would cost to have one at
home the answer was thousands
so what can be done to make it more
affordable think about actually
shopping around because i think then you
create more um more of a market and you
create people's you build people's
confidence as purchasers and i think
that will will help with making it more
accessible
and while the ideal solution for one
user may not be at all appropriate for
another the aim here at nadex seems
universal to help disabled people stand
on their own two feet
max preston
sky news
well there are some big name speakers
here at nadex 2 and joining us now is
paralympic legend 11 times gold medalist
baroness tani gray thompson thanks for
joining us what do you make of events
like this well nodex is amazing because
it's the one opportunity where disabled
people are able to see all the different
products that are available to them you
know it's that they're not always easily
available and unless you come here and
there are other shows around like it not
not this kind of size unless you come
here you're not going to know the things
that will make your life easier
a lot of the really impressive products
do you think perhaps they could be
slightly undermined by the fact that not
everyone's going to be able to afford
them particularly the people that need
them most it does seem that if you put a
tag disability product on something that
there is a greater cost um i'm sure the
companies will say you know there's
research and development because you
know there's always a reason why things
can be expensive but i think actually as
more disabled people are able to
purchase them
as things get more mainstream
then those costs should come down is
that key to make it more mainstream
absolutely you know actually companies
that just make general equipment need to
make it more disable friendly more
mum-friendly more older people-friendly
and you know we we just have to make it
because it makes such a difference to
disable people's lives it's a shame if
they can't afford them and a lot of
people don't realize that it's actually
quite difficult to get hold of a
suitable wheelchair just a basic
wheelchair for an individual yeah i'm
working on a project which is is looking
at improving wheelchair services there's
loads of good practice but it's a
postcode lottery wait times are too long
and getting the right chair means that
you can work you can go to school you go
to university you can pay taxes you can
contribute to society and we need to
make sure the public understands that
the right chair makes a huge difference
to a disabled person's life
brilliant thanks for speaking to us
you're watching swipe still to come
digging for victory shovel knight is
back
well look who else is here hurricane
hannah another paralympic champion hi
hannah cockroft what are you doing here
today uh so i'm here today i've just
done a talk on one of the stands just
i guess to inspire people and tell
disabled people that they can can do and
can be whatever they want to be have you
done that
just told them my story of where i've
come from and how i've got to where i am
and it's got quite a good response so
i'm quite happy with it and uh yeah it's
great to be here on such a massive
platform and a lot of people told you
yeah there's there's a lot of emphasis
here on independent living isn't there
and that's something that you do yeah
for me independence is really important
it's something that
for disabled people is taken away quite
easily and something that you really
have to fight to have so i think it's
important that people believe that they
can have it and and that's the first
step to actually gaining it so this
place is great because people can come
and see what they need for their
independence how they can get it how
they can just claim it all back and i
think that's really important we've been
taking a look at the the technology and
the innovation here um in racing
is that something that's that's quite
prevalent there's a lot of new tech
um the race chairs are all fairly
similar like there's not really anything
new when people try new things like try
to make the chair like carbon fiber make
a new wheel make make new things like
that can it get a bit unfair if you know
one country has better technology than
the other yeah exactly so there's a lot
of rules in place put by
by the ipc uh that kind of stops that
happening so we can develop things as
far as we want but actually if they
don't come within the rules then you
can't race it so actually the technology
was erasing kind of stand still and has
been stood still for a long time but it
works for us and that's fine are there
particular types of technology that you
really rely on either for racing or for
your own personal independent living i
guess for for me obviously my research
is important my daycare is really
important i need to be light and
maneuverable and and so i i always push
in the shawls of the top end for my
wrist
just because they work really well for
me but driving wise you know i have to
drive every single day so my hand
controls are really important that
i actually trust what they're about to
do so yeah i think when you look further
into life there's loads of technology
that helps me from day to day but i
think i kind of take it for granted
because it's always been there i've
always kind of had that access and known
what i need and what i want to do with
it what kind of innovations would you
really like to see in the future
uh for me i loved a car that drives
itself that'd be amazing driverless cars
oh yeah there's a lot of talk about
those yeah but uh i guess
mobility wise i think just it doesn't
even have to be technology it's just
more access just to make things a little
bit easier let's get the tubes
accessible the bus is accessible let's
make the big cities accessible and
you know make it a little bit more fun
to actually go and visit them that'd be
great
it's great to talk to you thanks for
joining us thank you
now we've got a night with a spade and a
brainy bouncing box it can only be time
for our games review here's holly
nielsen
shovel knight was originally released in
june 2014 for the 3ds wii u and
microsoft however now it's out on beta
ps4 and xbox one so everyone can enjoy
it now it's got a wonderful 8-bit retro
aesthetic to it it will really get the
nostalgia juices flowing and it's a
wonderful meeting between old and new
it's got some fantastic characters in it
and you fight with a shovel and you use
various techniques so you can use as a
pogo stick which is a bit reminiscent of
the old ducktales game for anybody
that'll remember that it's quite a
difficult game but multiple checkpoints
means that doesn't get too frustrating
it's got brilliant gameplay and it's
definitely one that you should look out
for box boy has a simple premise but
it's one that works really well
so it has a bit of a simplistic art
style but it's really adorable the
little box that you play as it's pretty
gorgeous and you can dress them up in
capes and sunglasses and things it's
really charming the premise is that you
spawn a number of different boxes and
use these boxes to make it through each
level the end of each level is your goal
the levels are quite short and it can be
a bit simple but there are over 150
levels so it's a great dip in and out of
game
well that's it for this week but don't
forget to stay up to date with all the
latest tech news on sky news for ipad
our smartphone app skynews.com and our
youtube playlist we'll see you again
next week bye-bye
protect protectyourbubble.com proud
sponsors of swipe on sky news